und damit herzlich willkommen meine
lieben freunde hier zudem fällt magic 5
1014 0 wie so nehme ich das auf ganz
einfaches ziel des spiels ist dass der
kamerad eigentlich funken raus wir
können hier verschiedene dinge
einstellen und dann mal schauen wie der
dementsprechende kurz sich dann an hört
hier wäre was können
uns auch einen schnell machen mal an
nahe die lakers die nation halten aber
was wollen diese blubberblasen
ganzheitlich will machen wir noch
abdominale tänzen und backwaren flachs
moment mal schauen was dann kommt schon
wieder diese blasen altar was wollen die
denn des flow density alter kann man das
auch einstellen was kommt aus euren
arsch wenn ihr friedman und spaß
erstellt euch noch vorfreude wird rein
kommt und ihr macht gerade so
was passiert wenn ich jeden hebel mal
nach ganz oben drücke ich will nicht
ich glaube meine nachbarn denken das
sich irgendwie behindert bin wird was es
hält sich doch nicht mehr gesund an
alter noch mal alles in die mitte das
wäre dann quasi sonnen standard 14 etwa
mal schauen was dabei rauskommt was mit
einer explosion oder so auf meine 14
berg bei mir ist dann halt auch noch so
immer eigentlich dass man da auch noch
eine 8 doch jetzt mal mach doch jetzt
mal dieses ich fühle mich richtig
behindert dass ich die scheißegal
spielen ohne witz also ich glaube damit
kann man kein komplettes video führen
dass wir jetzt ein bisschen zu wenig ich
bin grad hier bei mir bei viereinhalb
minuten aufnahmezeit
ich würde sagen wir müssen noch mal ein
anderes spiel jetzt mit in dieses video
mit reinem bei so ein spiel alleine will
ich nicht hochladen und wärme auf zu
blöd was würde besser zu diesem spiel
passen als einen idioten schon verloren
ach so ich das jetzt einfach nur dieses
ding direkt neben den titel wert der
start-button regal diät test simplen
klick und die square to begin presst die
red bic red button to continue christi
rectangle to continue rectangle heißt
doch rechteck also dass hier ohne wissen
seiner eltern schauen ja manchmal meine
videos weil die so sehen wollen was ich
mache und dann sehen die einfach haye
unser sohn hat ein video hochgeladen wo
der das wieso bin ich dann sehen die
einfach so ein video wo ich erst ein
simulator spieler und dann einen
idiotentest die decken auf wordpress die
blutbahnen three times denn die orange
button vorteils ok drei mal blau viermal
orange 12 31 234 ps
die picture of the cat ok kress de peron
cent denn die down rot weiß und ich
mache es auf meine tastatur ich
vollidiot und zwei presst rectangle
twice da bonn press die red button
einmal der gelbe button dann einmal der
blaue button und dann nochmal der gelbe
gelb blau gelb try to prove juni die
welt voll was die blätter arda quads
information rtti facebook ja ich bin
durchschnitt zweimal das quadrat 12 dann
fressen green button das ist genau das
was ich kann einfach warten und dann bin
ich schon jetzt auch da geb ich bin
keine smart nummer vier
die ovale continue
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das merken
kann einmal den roten kreis dann blau
grau blaues dreieck und zwei mal dass
das grüne ding und klug was mama ich bin
die mutter soll sich vor vorne machen
das ist doch nicht war als ob ich das
schon wieder durchgefallen bin man ja
roth allerdings hier rectangle roten
zweimal und an den grünen einmal blue
button dreimal und an den gelben wieder
mal noch geld oder weiter gelb gelb bei
der welt gebracht das war der ukraine
ich bin nur noch ein borderline idiot ok
ich hab' ich hab dich etwas geschafft
bonn press die blue button presse
jallohs where to continue drei mal blau
dreimal gelb 233 mal blau mal grün
dreimal platz drei grünen schweiz ihr
okay
blau grün gelb rot grün gelb ja
brilliance testbiotech basic
comingsoon.net ich bin brillant also das
was jetzt glaube ich wenn es euch
gefallen hatte ich habe mir einfach
gedacht während der aufnahme kommen
dieser partie mannschaft da kommt man
mehr mitmachen ist ein bisschen
einfallslos deswegen an dieser idiot
dran gehangen das hatte aufgepasst
eigentlich im ersten spiel wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr bock auf mehr
solche sachen habt könnt ihr meinen
kanal abonnieren wenn ihr bock drauf ich
würd's nicht machen ich lade eigentlich
sonst wirklich nur scheiße hoch und dann
sehen wir uns morgen wieder am montag
wenn ich aus meinem vier tage urlaub
zurück bin